dan Boy et c'est h
PARAD de tout côtés onentend plus que ça
un nouveau qui nous vient de làbas un
nouveau qui va faire dugât et comm ilut
prendre c'est une danse au rythme
merveilleux quand dans à ou bien à de
pas besoin de regard dans les yeux il a
simplement qu' être
heureux twist vous y viendrez tous twist
and twist et vous verrez tous twist and
twist le monde entier
twist un pied devant et les deux mains
fermé légèrement branché sur le côté
sans oublier surtout de pivoter encore
un effort vous
l'avez twist and twist vous y viendrez
tous twist and twist et vous verrez tous
twist twist le monde entier
twist
[Musique]
twist twist ai viendrez tous twist and
twist et vous verrez tous twist and
twist le monde entier twist
levé les deux mains fermé lcherement
branché sur le côté sans oublier surtout
de pivoter encore un effort vous
l'avez voilà c'est un oui commee ça
voilà bien change rien oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parfait